[Music]
foreign
the host of after show and today we have
a very exciting and very special episode
it is near and dear to my heart this
time of year I don't sleep I'm like a
kid at Christmas I love award season and
today we're going to be covering our
annual golden tomato Awards we're going
to be honoring the best of TV and movies
talking about those that had outstanding
critical reception and when I talk about
outstanding I am indeed also talking
about our panel today
two of my favorite people and this is
like my personal Dream Team
first of all we have comedian don't look
at me with those puppy dog eyes comedian
actor he's so funny every room he walks
in he lights it up Jay Washington will
get you everywhere you keep doing it but
I honestly mean it I appreciate it
seriously I always love working with the
two of y'all so when I heard it was the
three of us again I was like this works
but I'm happy to be back here and
talking to all Liz so I'm just gonna
keep listening
push alongs before I make you blush too
much he is the managing editor at
Fandango my longtime colleague and
friend and I used to call him the
Undisputed king of Twitter and while he
still is we have a new name for him
because he's been hanging out with the
top gun Maverick crew Executives cast
filmmakers producers so his new name he
has a call sign his name is slice yes Mr
Eric Davis yes that is
official it is a little pizza
I'm super excited to be here I haven't
been in person with you all in a while
and so be here in the studio talking
about the best of the best from last
year I think it's great it's like
virtual reality but it's actual reality
like it really changes the game so um so
for all of you guys who are wondering
how the heck do they choose the winners
because there's so many critically
acclaimed TV shows and movies the Auntie
just gets upped all the time so here's
how we do it we select the TV and movies
that have the highest tomato your scores
and then we apply our adjusted score
formula this formula gives a little
boost to TV shows and movies that have
outstanding critical reception and made
a lot of Buzz and it makes them rank a
little bit higher so we're going to be
listing off those winners for you today
we're going to start with TV we're going
to go to movies but just so you're not
like throwing your tablet if you
disagree with us or agree with us or
yelling at your TV or however you're
watching you get to have your say so
just scan the QR code that's on your
screen and that's going to open up our
fan poll and you can weigh in and you
can vote for all the categories in TV
and film and then in a couple of weeks
from now on our Rotten Tomatoes is wrong
podcast you can tune in to see the
results of that fan poll it's going to
Premiere in a couple of weeks and we
definitely want to hear your opinion see
if you agree or disagree with us on
everything so let's just jump right in
without further Ado to television kick
things off with TV mystery and Thriller
and the winner only murders in the
building season two what do you guys
think Congratulations by the way we'll
accept that award on their behalf look I
I I'm I'm an old school movie fan who
one of my favorite movies of all time is
Three Amigos with Steve Martin Chevy
Chase and Martin Short and so Steve
Martin and Martin Short just getting
together and doing anything is just call
me gold uh what's really impressed me
with this series is Selena Gomez like
she just kind of slid in between these
two legends and really held her own and
really did a fantastic job and and kind
of really it you know I think Amplified
her career as an actress because of this
show the writing is sharp you know I
think it had a perfect season one and
whenever you see that you're like that's
hard to follow up but they did with
season two I think it's really great the
story is good it keeps you guessing
they're really great together and I mean
when you have Perfect Chemistry like
that it's like you know it's capturing
magic in a bottle I think this show has
it I'm looking forward to the next
season which is going to have Paul Rudd
on it and Meryl Streep on it
Selena Gomez dropped a tick tock and was
like introducing hey guys we're back
shooting season three we got a surprise
and Paul robes like we got one of the
little surprise and Meryl Streep pops up
from behind the couch and she the person
like the neighbor the new neighbor in
the building have they said she's doing
it we just know she's in it but I want
to ask you because you are a comedian
there's something about like when you
put like you said you put her between
those two and it's the most unexpected
combination like it could have not
worked so what works about it it
couldn't have worked but when you have
two icons two veteran actors as well
yeah not just veteran comedians veteran
actors who understand okay we have to
help bring her up and not overshide her
we're gonna shine regardless yeah Steve
Martin and Martin Short no They're Gonna
Shine regardless this is what they do
but Selena Gomez is coming into entirely
different Lane and so to trust her her
to trust them the show Runners and
everybody all it does is Elevate the
show like you said second season top
season one which is very hard for a lot
of shows to do this show actually got to
the point where people who would never
normally watch it started watching it
they went back to season one to make
sure they caught up on everything from
there then go to season two so again
then you have season three coming up and
you're just excited I'm more excited for
Selena Gomez it is to like now she's
going even higher on a level Meryl
Streep Paul right you're adding all
these other actors that only thing they
can do is boost her up I'm excited they
won our tomato award because I feel like
Steve Martin and Martin Short are always
nominated for supporting and other
Awards ceremonies and I feel like it
splits the vote and they don't tend to
win so we get to give them an award I
just want to give an honorable mention
in this category the White Lotus was
also one of the nominees and that is my
I love only murders it's probably in my
top five of the year what White Lotus is
probably my number one number one show
of the year the next category is TV
we're getting one show two Awards
because they want in two categories so
we're gonna put them together it was TV
drama and TV returning meaning it was a
returning series and the winner was and
they just got uh love at the Critics
Choice Awards Better Call Saul season
six finally getting its due it was kind
of the the show that kept getting
nominated and people would always say
it's the best show in television and you
know not enough not enough awards were
given so here we are giving it the uh
tomato award what do you guys think I
was hoping this wasn't a thing where
they would let this show pass and it
never gets the recognition it does yeah
you know all six seasons happen and you
hear well it was consistently nominated
nominated nominated and never won
anything but I think not just saying
that to be like oh well they finally
decided to give it to him out of here
you go it's like no this season
culminated everything people have been
wanting in six seasons of this show
knowing how Better Call Saul you're
hearing the backstory of Saul and to see
the end of Saul everything worked out
yeah yeah I think it's the SEC the
success of this show is just that what's
great about it is that it tells its own
story uh but it's also amplifying and
enhancing your experience of Breaking
Bad at the same time and it's tying up
loose ends and doing all of that the
cast is great and so I always feel like
when you can kind of have a show that
does its own thing that you're invested
in but then it's also enhancing your
experience of something else that you
love like I love it when like Star Wars
does stuff like that like it just makes
the experience as a whole more memorable
and I think the show just did an
outstanding job talk about catching
lightning in a bottle twice like we did
again you know with only murders but you
know to do six seasons and and you know
end with bang I think they did a great
job and Bob Odenkirk really like hats
off to him for for nailing this and and
doing such a great job okay so here's my
admission you know there's always famous
TV shows and films that you've never
seen like one Leonardo DiCaprio admitted
he had never seen like gone with the
winter one of those things I've never
seen an episode of Breaking Bad and I've
never seen an episode of Better Call
Saul there's my confession I want a
confession from each of you because I
can't be alone no no I can't beat that
confession right now maybe we get to
something else but I don't know well
let's is there is there one that's off
top of your head no no it's off my head
Davis I do have a confession I've never
seen the wire
but that is still one that I need to sit
down and and kind of schedule into my
life knowing that it's going to be
memorable yeah but that's the issue is
if you get behind in some of these
things and I do believe and we're now
seeing like Game of Thrones went back to
that Weekly release yeah or you know
House of the dragon and some shows I
think are better binged and some I think
are better with that slow build week to
week like White Lotus crushed my soul
with having to wait week to week but it
actually enhanced I think everything
because it was such a water cooler show
that everybody was talking about and I
literally could not wait I was in Europe
for the last episode and I was on my VPN
trying to cheat the assistant so I could
get on and watch it it was like it's
that kind of a thing okay moving on the
award for TV comedy went to Atlanta
season four
one of the things I loved about this
season is Donald Glover's such a genius
at what he does he ended this show in a
way nobody expected because I know a lot
of people saw the finale and were like
wait this is this this is it it's like
yeah sometimes you don't have to have
this perfect resolution in a show right
that never gave you a perfect resolution
like The Sopranos The Sopranos never
gave us This brilliant ending yeah just
never gave you a perfect resolution to
anything and so for the way everything
happened where people thought is this
all just a dream from Darius and it's
like no isn't it it is it isn't I'm
confused what happens to Paperboy what
happens with Lottie and you know van and
and and and earn and all these different
things and you have all these different
questions but it's just like hey it's
out here and so especially after season
three with the way they had to film
everything and everything being so
Anthology in a sense it's you know the
way it was done I still loved season
four and I I think it was definitely one
of the top comedies of last year yeah I
can see it I what I love about Donald
Glover is that he just always reinvents
himself
in his music in in his TV and anything
that he does uh and I I go back all the
way back to Donald Glover when he
started with that comedy troop uh and
they were they would they kind of made a
couple of funny movies and then he kind
of broke off on his own thing and really
developed himself as an artist and you
see it in the episodes of the show like
there's one crazy episode where it's
like a fake documentary about Goofy and
like like stuff like that you just don't
see in other shows I love that they gave
him the freedom to just continue to have
fun and take risks and I hope that we
see more TV like that I hope Donald
Glover gets more opportunities to do
that versus like taking him and making
him Lando like I would rather see Donald
Glover creating stuff and and starting
it but like I would rather see that
version of Donald Glover than than
putting him in like a Star Wars but I
think people know that about him now
like let him do his thing because he can
do so much the thing is he starred in
Atlanta but didn't have to be the star
of Atlanta right he allowed all the
other three main cast members to shine
that is why we have Brian Tyree Henry on
such a a rise that's why we have a
meteoric Roswell Keith Stanfield and
zazzy Beach because he understood who he
had around him he knew he was his own
star let me elevate invade others you're
making me cry yeah
I'm very emotional this week all these
Awards make me like get Misty for people
to have you for people did either of you
watch the bear because that was also in
this game that was like my favorite show
of the Year by confession I didn't watch
it and I know people are going to be mad
because again it said my hometown to
Chicago one of my buddies Corey
Hendricks is in the show and he was like
so you haven't seen the show yet I was
like hey bro I was busy but I do want to
catch up with it because I've seen a lot
of people do nothing but Rave about it
how great it is it's fantastic my two
favorite comedies of the year are the
bear and Abbott Elementary and I'm a
little bummed to not see Abbott like
higher in in the golden tomato Awards
because I just think that I feel like
next year it's gotta be nice you know
what I mean like I feel like maybe next
year that's going to be the gym but also
network television who knew yeah no I I
honestly it's like it's like holding it
like that and like detective shows on
CBS they're like holding up right here I
know I know okay next category is TV
superhero we know there was a lot of
Marvel that Miss Marvel season one was
our winner oh loved it I told everybody
when I first saw the first two episodes
I said first of all Marvel did something
completely different this is like an MCU
Nickelodeon show it's in the vein of
Scott Pilgrim Vs the World and you're
gonna love it it's a different eye it's
from a different set of eyes than any
other film we've seen or TV show and
they did that Aman villani is a star
plain and simple she's a star in this
and to watch everything with the
cultural aspect we get of that that was
the biggest thing for me they opened
everyone's eyes to a brand new culture
how things really are and I will admit I
laughed the hardest when I discovered
that the main bad guy of Miss Marvel is
the government I was right think about
it damage control the government is the
bad guy in that show
and you're like holy wow they pulled
this off oh yeah I mean and shout out to
Miss Marvel this Show's like a 98 I
think as of as of this this conversation
which is the highest uh any Marvel
anything movies TV like is at the top I
think it's it's tremendous I mean I'm
somebody who grew up in Staten Island
which is right next to Jersey City spent
time in Jersey City uh I think the fact
that they kind of came in and and really
again brought life to Jersey City and
the people of Jersey City while weaving
in this superhero story and some MCU
nods and I think mon villani is a great
is a great find and I think she's going
to be now in the Marvels and so to kind
of connect TV now to the movies is that
that was the ultimate promise when
Marvel came to TV it's like how are they
gonna kind of toss to one another
um and I I just think it did a fantastic
job and also shout out to She-Hulk
because I think that was another show
this summer yeah
also did what I think Miss Marvel did in
terms of giving you a different
perspective a different POV a different
kind of way to experience Marvel that
you haven't experienced Marvel yet yeah
it's pissing some people off but you
know what like I think I think you have
to continue to reinvent the MCU from
different perspectives in order for it
to have the longevity that they wanted
that I think this was the own She-Hulk
was the one thing where they were like
yeah it's gonna piss people off we know
it we know it but we're going to roll
with it because when you realize how
long ago the show was written yeah from
when it dropped and how they predicted a
lot of these reactions they were gonna
get yeah you know that that's genius on
yourself to know no they're gonna be mad
at this so we're gonna play to it here
then they're gonna be mad at this so
we're gonna do this but then we're going
to do this thing at the end that's going
to show you why we did everything yeah
yeah yeah okay think about it it's like
it's it's one of the most reactive to
social media shows yes it is like it's
very cognizant of what it is and what
it's doing and who will like it and who
won't like it and they make it part of
the show itself
you know it's like it's like this is
what Meadow looks like in the social
media age you know and I thought that it
was very smart Okay so speaking of
pissing people off the winner of three
categories it was our TV overall winner
and you'll see where I'm going with this
in a second it's also on our TV sci-fi
fantasy category and TV new series
category and I'm talking about the
spin-off to Game of Thrones that the
ending pissed a lot of people off and
then there they followed up with a whole
new series a prequel series House of the
Dragon season one was the winner overall
for TV shout out because that was my
second favorite show of the year next to
White Lotus I love House of the Dragon
just absolutely love it I hated some
people's reactions on social media like
oh is this what this is you're just
introducing people it's a prequel show
oh I'm sorry do you not like a slow burn
people because this is another thing is
what worked about it to me it was every
episode was filled with so much tension
and so much brilliant character building
Patty Constantine I can't believe he
hasn't gotten more nominations for
things because he was unbelievable talk
about like a character Arc a beautiful
character Arc but I thought and I was
like super super like how are they going
to do the younger and older versions of
these characters and they had the I'm
sorry balls to do these time jumps that
at the beginning of a new episode when
they did a time Jump it took me like 30
seconds where I'd be like hold on I
wanted to see the X Y and Z years before
but then they had me in the next minute
and I'm like oh my gosh like the way
that they paced that show was Unreal
yeah it was really smart and I think it
was a great example of watching the
entirety of Game of Thrones play out and
and looking at what really worked from
that series and then kind of reshaping
it and Reinventing it and and bringing
it back back I felt like House of the
Dragon started in a more accessible way
I feel like those first like several
Game of Thrones episodes of season one
are long and like I'm like who's over
here on this island like what like it
took me like Eight Episodes just to
figure out what was happening in season
one of Game of Thrones but I feel like
they they looked at that and they really
made this one like you can get in right
from the start I think casting his
lights out on this series it really it
really upped the ante um and yeah I
think the risky time jumps were super
cool and and big and were different and
I think they just they they made really
smart moves that you can tell they paid
attention to what worked and what didn't
in Game of Thrones and they they
reinvented it here I'm glad you
mentioned that because one of the
biggest things they paid attention to
was the opening credit sequence remember
when it started it was something
different and then this they got a lot
of feedback and pushback and they were
like uh okay so go back to the original
Game of Thrones music and they did yeah
and if for some reason just change the
feel as far as Patty Constantine him is
viserys spawned so many memes I was
gonna say that me the means of him
like of Ben Affleck being him it was
just great because again that's me again
I saw that one you can constantly catch
the pop cultures I dice yeah and that's
what this show did yep they did and they
made stars of people like Millie Alcock
nobody knew who she was and now she's
like getting all these offers and like
when you can take somebody who not a lot
of people know about and not just one
person but so many I mean obviously of
Matt Smith that everybody a lot of
people were tuning in for
um I just you reminded me of something
if you could give a golden tomato Award
for best opening of a series like the
opening credits who would you give it to
wow I would give it to White Lotus
because that White Lotus but you know
what history thing I always have to
watch the opening stranger things like
there's something about that music that
gets my head into the space that they
want it to be in and so like I always
watch the opening music I hear it and
see that's when you know it's good
because when as soon as you said it I
could hear it you got it I got it
playing Shuffle Peacemaker oh Peacemaker
James Gunn made something when you
cannot skip it because you want to see
this damn stuff people were starting to
learn the dance number off of this
Peacemaker hands down for me yeah yeah
for most creativity and most like sort
of Buzz social media until the end of
that season I was like I don't know if I
have to watch this dance again right now
Eight Episodes but stranger things you
got me on every episode
like it puts you out gets you in the
mood in like 15 seconds you're like okay
I'm ready I'm ready all right we are
going to list off some of the other
categories before we move on to the film
winners so I'm just going to mention
these real quick so for TV animated the
winner was legend the legend of Vox
Machina season one TV horror Interview
with a Vampire Season one was our winner
TV miniseries Irma vep season one was
the winner TV romance Heart Stopper
season one TV True Crime Blackbird which
I talked about and TV docu-series the
last movie stars so congratulations we
humbly accept the award on all of Europe
all right we're going to move on to our
movie winners and there were a lot of
categories and we're going to go over
six categories and discuss the winners
starting with comedy which is hard to do
hard to do in Hollywood and get people's
butts in those seats these days but
banshees of inner Sharon was our winner
I should say the Banshees of inner
Sharon was our winner I did not see this
one by chance so Eric I believe yeah no
it's it's really good it's Gotta I I
what I love the most about this is just
its premise it's it's just so you know
it's the the breaking up of a friendship
this is what I hated about this premise
but I thought it was just interesting it
was uncomfortable it was well written it
was set in an environment that was
unfamiliar but had so much character to
it you have Jenny the donkey which
became a viral sensation uh and I think
you know there's so much chemistry there
uh between these two guys and I I think
that that you know uh I thought it was
really great and it was unique and it
was unexpected and uh and there was a
lot of unexpected kind of moments in it
as these these two friends are breaking
up and you know I think it was somebody
said You know open in the early goings
of the movie where he's just like why
don't you want to be friends with me
anymore and it's just like I just don't
like you anymore and it's just like
that's James this was the premise
as we go on because then he says if you
talk to me or engage with me again
here's what I'm gonna do yeah he's gonna
cut off his fingers and he's like this
uh he's a musician
this is what happens these decisions
that you don't necessarily understand
but at the same time it's like
heartbreaking and it's funny and I I
always appreciate comedies that can kind
of thread that line of like humanity and
that even though this world is
completely unfamiliar like you get it
and like you understand it to a certain
degree and you can apply it to your life
and you know I think there's something
really heartbreaking about this film as
well as something very uh dry humor to
it and dark humor to it that I think is
different and unique and that's why
people respond I see I see it as a drama
I don't like you as a person you talk to
me I'm gonna cut off your friend okay
you just can't wait to watch it now
right no it's actually excellent it's
nine at 90 97 on the Tomato Meter right
now and it is a you know getting a lot
of award season buzz it won a ton of
Golden Globes it's doing it's Martin
McDonough who of course did three
Billboards he's so great with characters
characterization he wrote and directed
and um yeah I mean Colin
um Farrell is one of the Front Runners
for best actor a lot of people are
saying you know he had such a good year
with the Batman that he's potentially
going to win for this
um and yeah I mean people people are
just loving this film I'm more like for
me this season I'm about like this award
season and winners I'm all about the
Blockbusters which we will get to but I
wanted to mention before we move along
my favorite comedy of the year in this
category
um that was an honorable mention mention
was Nicholas Cage's the unbearable
weight of massive talent I have heard so
much about that's what I have to see it
is definitely on my list I've been so
busy everybody was like because you it's
not what you think it is at all the
script is unbelievable I even know how
they wrote it yeah really smart really
funny uh Nicholas Cage playing Nicolas
Cage I mean you can't get better than
that so yeah I thought it was really
inventive deserves to be there I also
love the lost city with uh
like honestly there's something we had
Brad Pitt and bullet train we had Brad
Pitt in Babylon like Brad Pitt in the
lost city is my favorite Brad Pitt of
the year
is one of my favorite scenes in any
movie of the entire year this is such an
underrated game you were talking about
rom-coms before and I feel like you know
we're still getting them but we're
getting like one or two a year yeah and
I'm glad I was glad to see that one get
like you know do well at the box office
and had a lot of fans to it you know
because I think I think they did a good
a good job and I think you're gonna need
to see Channing Tatum and Sandra Bullock
do more together and Brad is a sidekick
and then you know you had Radcliffe
playing the villain like it was yeah no
they were all upgraded so great and yeah
sequel make it all right sci-fi fantasy
category this is a movie
that everyone is talking about and I am
talking about everything everywhere all
at once potentially could win the Oscar
for Best Picture it is certified fresh
at 95 on the Tomato Meter people are
obsessed this movie to me has a
trajectory of what parasite had of what
Coda has where it just is this
Groundswell it's the little movie that
could that people just keep talking
about and through Word of Mouth it
becomes part of the mainstream
conversation and potentially could win
at the Oscars and it won our award for
sci-fi fantasy Michelle yo has
everybody's Hearts yeah and this will be
consistently going as a mother going in
a wife going through everything and a
daughter as well uh T1 I can't remember
pronouncing last is not his last name
excuse me him is Wayman is phenomenal
great Stephanie soon the daughter when
you watch everything she goes through
but Jamie Lee Curtis who I had to watch
it twice in the beginning was like wait
that's you know because it didn't look
like her at first when she's sitting at
the desk you're like wait is that that
can't be and it's Jamie Lee Curtis and
to watch this iteration
um again as a superhero fan we got
Doctor Strange Multiverse Madness this
year and I bring that up because
everything everywhere all at once did
the Multiverse better than Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness did it
showed us a variety of universes how the
decisions in one world can change
another and all these different things
and the story is just so well done there
are so many laugh out loud moments with
this I think it is the best picture of
the Year hands down yeah it's definitely
wild and inventive and I the fact that
the Daniels you know are are like
winning Best Director Awards right now
like looking at what they've done
previously like I would have never in a
million years thought that those two
guys brilliant day by the way I think
they are brilliant guys but the fact
that they are that they have made it
here I think is a phenomenal story I
think my favorite Awards narrative this
year is the kihu Kwan and
winning those supporting categories I
think that is the best Awards narrative
that's happening right now and he is
phenomenal the first call that he got
funnily enough was from Kevin feige
asking him to join the MCU in Loki
season two so he's gonna go from one
Multiverse narrative to another
Multiverse narrative but I think you're
right uh and I I imagine Marvel Studios
watch this film carefully to see like
just how they pulled it off uh in within
one film and telling a complete story
the families great the cast is great I
mean is it as accessible as Coda no
right and so I think that if it doesn't
win best picture I think if the
accessibility of it and how Wild of it
uh is May turn some Oscar voters off but
I definitely think it's going to be up
there and it's going to be you know
between that and like Maverick and the
fablemans for sure I'm gonna be slightly
controversial
I didn't love this movie I loved the
performances but I think maybe my head
is so chaotic that it was just too much
chaos was just it bounced off me I was
like it's too much I can't take it but I
that said the performances were some of
my favorite performances just overall as
a movie it just 100 it just didn't work
for me in the sense is I just kept I
kept feeling like I was caught in a
Vortex that I couldn't get out of it was
the chaotic but it's also you know we're
in this day and age of people who say
they watch movies but still have their
phones in their hands this is one of
those movies you cannot do that no oh I
did
see that's why that's why no the second
time meaning I tried a second time I'm
like I'm missing something here I'm
missing something but that said Michelle
yo is one of my favorite actresses hands
down
um key is I mean the fact that his this
is the narrative this year with award
season of between him and Brendan
Frasier of these people who genuinely
are winning Awards and you feel the pain
of all the years they didn't work yeah
and all the years that no one would give
them a shot and how much they truly get
on that stage and appreciate the award
and appreciate the moment and are in the
moment okay so we're gonna move on
this movie won two Awards it won for
animation and streaming for best
animation and streaming film of the year
no surprise Guillermo del Toro's
Pinocchio what more I mean it is
brilliant he is brilliant
thousand days to film this movie stop
motion animation the amount of detail
and painstaking process that he went
through to make this movie but every
single shot in frame you feel is made
out of love you have chills watching it
throughout I don't know how you felt
yeah I think Gamo is is one of the the
best uh filmmakers and and crafts I mean
he's just phenomenal and he's a super
warm guy and he'd love that he has for
not just like genre filmmaking but
storytelling and I think I think it's
all poured into this film and really
poured into everything that that he does
and I love that like Netflix gave him an
opportunity to make this because there
you know I think a lot of people passed
on it and that's kind of the story of
his career is people passing on his
ideas and then somebody takes a chance
and it's like amazing
um and he's still going through that
even after winning best at picture for
the shape of water right he's still
struggling to kind of get his stories
told at the mountains of Madness is
another one that he's been struggling
for many years to make and it kind of
still blows my mind that people aren't
investing in him more because I think
he's just a brilliant Storyteller I want
to I think animation yeah this one had
it on lock with the surprising thing
there is is best streaming movie if you
think of all of the movies yeah that
come out that you know on streaming
services that this one is the best uh I
think that that is is a super notable
Award right there do you think it helps
that the other Pinocchio film with Tom
Hanks people wanting to see the
difference
it does I thought you were going to say
does it help that all the other
streaming movies were not good
that's the drop this year people were
like
oh my watch
have been a narrative this year is that
people kind of fell off like streaming
film and what that was a beautiful thing
about theater coming back and Top Gun in
that narrative is you know but I
interrupted you guys no no worries it
was just the open the doors were open to
theaters again and full and people
wanted to be out but you had the
Pinocchio film with Tom Hanks and a lot
of people did not film that movie so to
see something different in a stop-motion
animated way with Guillermo del Toro by
the way who his name just resonates and
it's not saying Tom hanks's name doesn't
resonate but you're like all right I
gave you want to try let's see the other
and now this gets the bigger praise and
so that spreads the word yeah that was
why well and he understands that like if
you go back to these original fairy
tales like they're all pretty crazy and
you know I think a lot of people look at
these Tales because they discovered him
in the Disney cartoons and so it's this
very sanitized version of the fairy tale
uh and that's what people know of
Pinocchio they don't know these Original
Stories the original Tales the original
books where they they kind of took some
risks and they were a little crazy and
they're they were horror elements to
them and I think Guillermo del Toro is a
filmmaker that really appreciates where
they originally came from and telling
those stories and I think because this
was a unique version of Pinocchio that
we hadn't experienced yet I think that's
why it resonated more this is such a
strong category this year and I really
wanted to mention a couple others that I
just love turning red I absolutely loved
that film growing up in Toronto Puss in
Boots The Last Wish was also uh
something that people really did Antonio
Banderas back at it unless yeah you
can't go wrong you know and I I you know
I I I kind of crack on Netflix sometimes
for their movies but I do I want to
shout out Netflix for their animation
choices and I think every year they are
they have a movie that's always in the
mix and I think they take risks with
their animation content and I think
they're making some you know some really
interesting moves that you know I would
put them beside Pixar and Disney and say
that Netflix animation I think that's
the some of the strongest content
they're making right right now I think
in at least in the film space is in the
animated space yeah it's there's some
great
um Marcel the Shell where she's that's
another one that people love
um okay so I'm gonna have to defer to
the two of you on this next category kid
is my least favorite genre and I did not
see this movie but the winner in the
horror genre was X I love Dex I loved I
remember a friend and I we went to go
see it I just want you want to go see
this x movie sure and you watch it and
it's nothing what you expect at all give
us the premise so it's about uh it's
like the 70s there's this fledgling like
porn company they want to make a porn in
a certain way but they go rent out a
farmhouse from this couple this is
before like airbnbs and so you got to
director his girlfriend who's one of the
Stars another girl she's a rising star
you've got Kid Cudi Scott muskooter
who's who's amazing in this he's the
male guy he's the male star then you
have the cinematographer and his young
girlfriend they're both filming she's
doing sound
and come to find out the older lady that
lives in the house with the older man
she remembers the days of her youth when
she was beautiful and vibrant and stuff
and all of a sudden just goes crazy out
of nowhere and when it happens you're
just like wait as a female I can relate
to that she just starts murdering people
like it sounds like a comedy you would
like oh don't get me wrong you're good
you watch this you will laugh at a lot
and a lot that's good I I think what's
so great about this film is that it is a
throwback to the 70s but it's also a
throwback to a kind of horror that
doesn't really exist these days and it's
the kind of horror that is not afraid to
be sexy and is not afraid to turn you on
uh and then once it turns you on then it
brings the crazy out and I feel like a
lot of horror in the 70s and and into
the 80s that you know they did that
really well and then we kind of started
saying uh let's not have too much sex in
our horror movies anymore you know uh
but I do think that there's a lot of
value there in kind of taking an
audience in One Direction action and
then kind of completely flipping it and
now you're in another Direction I think
this film does that really well I think
it's actually more successful than Pearl
which was a prequel yes but I would
recommend watching X and pearl uh for
that experience and they're making a
third one now
that said like I think a 90s yeah and so
I'm curious to see what what director Ty
West kind of take on the 90s horror and
what that genre looked like back then
but more horror more sex and horror or
less like more like kind of you know
look at the old school Friday the 13th
for you kill the kids they was getting
these so you have me I turn you on I'm
gonna be watching this thing
the best horror I think is that kind of
horror that takes you in One Direction
and then pulls you into another one
because she plays Maxine and pearl in
this movie which you don't realize at
first and then you're like wait and then
there's a scene between the two of them
that just for it's it freaks you out so
much of what it does you two really sold
me on this my and I I would also shout
out Barbarian another Hard movie from
the year that also in this and not not
very the same but takes a left turn uh
and that left turn goes crazy and I like
that it kind of takes you in One
Direction and then it says nope we're
gonna take you here we're gonna put you
over here and this is how you're
experiencing the film for the rest of
the time I like it when movies do that
you didn't see Barbarian because you
don't like horror did you I like I liked
it but I was really to the point with
Barbarian I was like both of them
deserve to die yeah no I mean if you
watch it you'll see what you were like
they both of the leads deserve to go
yeah yeah I mean look you can you could
you could poke a lot of holes in that
movie Once you step away from it and
look back on it but I love the risk that
it takes yes halfway through I think
it's great all I keep hearing about that
movie is no little as possible going
into it yeah
as possible which I know nothing so but
you really had to be on the other one
shout out to the black phone and smile I
thought they did a good job too yeah no
it was a great okay so this is a genre
that there are a lot of movies coming
out in the genre and that is comic book
and we're gonna have a lot of things to
say about this category but the Batman
was the winner in this category totally
concur absolutely loved the Batman
that's kind of the movie of the year yes
I will give it that indeed I just think
for me personally my only pick my only
little nitpick I felt like was a little
too long that's every movie these days
is a little bit too long I feel like I
come out of every movie now maybe it's
because we see so many movies
um and maybe if you're buying a ticket
you know a couple times a year you're
going to the movies a few times a year a
few times you know every few months
maybe you wanna but as a film critic I'm
always like that was 20 minutes too long
yeah yeah it's interesting I think the
Batman uh from a technical point I I
think it's phenomenal terminal I think
there are some sequences in this that I
think Matt Reeves is a phenomenal
filmmaker I thought it was a really
interesting introduction to Batman kind
of very different Batman than we've ever
seen before I thought the cast was great
I thought Colin Farrell was really great
as the penguin I'm surprised that he's
not in more supported conversations for
that role but I'll be honest with you
though I I wasn't as emotionally
connected to the film like if I look at
the film I was most emotionally
connected to it would be wakanda forever
I thought like that film yeah I was a
lot more invested in that film than I
was in the Batman but I was I guess
maybe more visually stimulated by the
Batman if that makes sense you know like
I I you know but like for me I'm an
emotional Watcher and the films that
have my heart are the films that I tend
to go towards more and wakanda forever
had my heart this one did not have my
own I've ever had my heart and when I
say the best movie for the Batman it's
the best overall there are Parts about
wakanda forever just as much I didn't
like just as much as you know the Batman
I felt like there's certain story
elements that they didn't need to have
but I understood why they were there
because I was like okay the first black
panther is its own Standalone film yeah
this one would kind of forever had so
much to tackle
right out the gate as we know they came
out the gate and gave you the emotion of
Chadwick's passing like they got it out
the way and the rest of the movie
reflected on that how they dealt with
that and then the introduction of these
characters and again I there was a lot
of heart in it Leticia Wright is amazing
and Angela Bassett if she does not get
her Oscar finally for this performance
there is something wrong with everything
I think she's a front runner at this
point she has to be yeah that's it's
it's it's a done deal I mean she's
winning every yeah I feel like it's a
done deal yeah I think the film could
have could have been in that best
picture race too and I think if it
wasn't for like your avatar and your top
gun Maverick I think you'd see wakanda
forever in there and I still think that
it has a shot of getting the best
picture nomination do you think Colin
would be in the uh supporting actor race
had he not done banshees do you think he
would have they would have pushed that
narrative more maybe maybe but he you
know I think what what I struggle with
he's not in the Batman a lot like he's
got like maybe two or three scenes yeah
and it came out a long time and he
doesn't have a scene where it's just
like that's your Oscar eclipse see that
they're gonna play right but I do feel
like maybe if he had another couple of
scenes and banshees wasn't here there
would be a little bit more of a of a
support for for him for supporting yeah
I thought Robert was really great I
thought he was so interesting in it I
love the smokey eye a girl loves a man
in a smoky you can always keep that in
mind but no I just thought I thought the
makeup not only that but the makeup was
great the Prosthetics you know for Colin
unrecognizable was great without that
scene where the you know they turned the
camera on the side and the fire and the
you know like some of those scenes
became iconic I see what you're saying
though it's interesting do you but I
don't think they were I think it felt
very film Noir very glossy very like
but the thing about Matt Reeves is like
I love him as a filmmaker his his movies
tend to be a little emotionally cold uh
and Batman himself as a character is
emotionally cool right and so I'm
curious to see as they progress through
these movies if they figure out a way
for the audience to kind of feel a
little bit more invested in these
characters I think Batman's oh always
had that issue as a character and so I'm
curious to see how they progress you
know when you talk about Batman the part
two you know as we come into his part
two thinking about the Dark Knight
thinking about Burton's part two I think
a lot of people there gonna be a lot of
eyes on that part too as being maybe the
film that defines his Batman story so
I'm looking more at that this felt like
a starter a visually spectacular starter
but I'm looking to be a little bit more
invested in your characters and their
journey and and I want to see that more
this one won
three categories
film overall wide and action adventure
and was our overall like I said winner
for Best Picture
this year
t g m my favorite movie of the year top
gun Maverick
s
with all the great emotions you want to
just enjoy yourself for almost two for
two hours that's what top gun Maverick
is you want to watch Tom Cruise realize
how short he really is in real life Tom
Cruise Maverick top top gun Maverick
excuse me yeah look my favorite movie of
the year I think it it's a film that
feels like a throwback but it also feels
very modern it gives you ever like
you're laughing you're cheering you're
feeling heartache you're crying you're
on the edge of your seat like in terms
of a movie saying we're gonna give you
the buffet of everything that you want
to experience as a moviegoer but do it
well and and have a tight script this
movie does that it does a great job of
nodding to the original Top Gun but you
just don't have to have seen the
original Top Gun but it does enhance the
experience and I think Cruz is great I
think the cast The all the the pilots
the young Pilots that they found were
fantastic the fact that they're all in
these planes flying you see their
reactions you you feel the fact that
they were doing this themselves I think
that that adds to it and then I honestly
we don't get a lot of really memorable
soundtrack songs this year and I think
them bringing Lady Gaga in I think that
hold my hand music that song Not only
does it play over the credits but they
use the melody of it throughout the film
and they see it inside the film and we
don't see a lot of that these days we
saw it in the 90s and 80s not these days
and so it's a great soundtrack movie and
it just really does everything right
um and I I mean it's just fantastic so I
mean yeah lights it deserves everything
that it does it deserves best picture
the the reunion of sorts of Iceman and
Maverick is the most emotional thing I
think you see on screen because all we
already knew about Val Kilmer in real
life and again when you get that first
early text from Ice and Maverick Texan
in the bar and matter of fact even when
he walks in the Top Gun and he sees his
picture you have these little moments
and it's all building up to the two of
them together in person and again
everything else around it everybody
flying the planes watching him at the
very beginning go mock tanning and watch
him go look we only need 10 not 10.1 not
10.2 but him still being who he is him
teaching the pilots be like that but
look kind of pullback if you've got to
and then like no we can do this we're
the best everything hit on all cylinders
with this yeah and you know we're
talking about Awards and this one our
award and we're talking about award
season and this is the first time in a
long time where we could have a Titanic
year where a blockbuster wins best
picture I'm all for it I would love that
to happen I don't know if it's going to
happen there's a shot maybe I mean
there's a shot the way it's talked about
again just how hugee felt seeing it at
Cinema con I've I know people who went
three four times to the movies to watch
this movie in particular so you know and
then who's to say how the voters go but
it does have a shot but then you have
top gun Maverick everything everywhere
all at once tar seems to be a front
runner now so you have all these
different movies it's just like what's
going to sway these voters which way
yeah and you the Oscars are a little
complicated they have something called
the preferential ballot so it's not just
about like the movie that gets the top
vote but it's also like the movie that
gets like the second and your third and
your fourth and your fifth vote and I
think the thing that benefits top gun
Maverick is everybody's gonna have it in
their top three yeah uh because it's
just that kind of movie for everybody
and so I think that's why it may have a
shot at getting that best picture and
I'm curious to see I hope it gets it I
think Blockbusters kind of need it
um but I I look at like what a best
picture should be yeah and I look at
what that film is achieved and I'm like
that that is what a best picture should
be in my opinion 100 but I think we've
gotten used to in the last couple years
the last few years has all been about
the Nomad lands and and that kind of
movie and I think we've sort of trained
ourselves to thinking that a smaller
movie a small sort of like gritty
whatever movie that nobody wants that
nobody watched deserves the best picture
yeah and I feel like and that didn't
used to be the way it was like in the
late 90s early 2000s like bigger films
were winning things you know anyone
always Blockbusters per se for
everybody's probably listening and
watching going well they weren't
Blockbusters of course they weren't the
Blockbuster but they were bigger movies
Forrest Gump or toppo or or Titanic or
Lord of the Rings Return To The King
like I felt like yeah like you you make
a good point of like that mid to late
90s early 2000s there was this era where
like those big movies were being
recognized as best picture but now we've
gotten into this way where and I think
that's to a certain degree why award
show those are struggling is because a
lot of these best picture nominees are
films that people just haven't seen and
they don't know of or they're not
connecting with and they're maybe two a
little too high brow and that's not to
say that there isn't room for those
films to be there but I think that these
Blockbuster films that connect with a
lot of people on a big scale deserve a
seat at the table yeah and I think it's
starting to change and this is you know
there's been a couple years coming you
know with black panther being nominated
and that and I hopefully if it doesn't
happen this year I don't know what's
going to happen again but a couple
honorable mentions RR was in this
category one of my favorite movies of
the year that movie is incredible if you
have not seen it I oh my God I didn't
know I saw the trailer like when I first
saw the trailer and I remember my
buddies Jason and Ashley Robinson showed
me the trailer it was like you gotta
watch this trailer and I was like what
is this it was just I'm seeing lions and
tigers all this jumping and they're like
oh this is nothing compared to the movie
and it's three hours
that flow by
Flow by it's wild and I'm happy for its
success because I think it's also
putting in the Indian Cinema uh you know
on a bigger stage you know and a lot of
a lot of my friends that that watch a
lot of Indian Cinema they they kind of
joke about RR because they're like where
have you been like this is what they're
they're that's what they do you know but
I think our RR just had a like a much
higher budget but like you know I I
think this is putting that kind of
Cinema back on the map I think we're
seeing a lot more of those movies kind
of come over to the United States uh at
least at Fandango we're seeing a lot of
them in the in the ticket sales like top
top 10 yeah you know and so I I'm happy
for Indian Cinema and for all of those
fans to have that kind of representation
because we we don't see those films
represented in this way and and so you
know congrats to RR for breaking through
for sure wrap up everybody we're gonna
do a quick minute tension of the rest of
the winners in the film categories
documentary was fire of Love
congratulations drama foreign language
film and limited happening kids and
family the winner was Royal dolls
Matilda the Musical hopefully I
pronounced that correctly even though I
did read his books as a child I never
knew how to pronounce his name correct
me if I'm wrong mystery thriller ah what
we talked about before Glass Onion a
Knives Out mystery romance was girl
picture congratulations to all of our RT
golden tomato winners I want to thank
you both Jay Washington tell everybody
where they can find you yes absolutely
thank you again I love working with both
of you and being you all being here with
you all you all just amazing in general
likewise all the love yes uh Twitter
Instagram Facebook and miss and Tick
Tock and Mr J Washington m-r-j-a-y you
should not spell Washington uh the man
Titan podcast where I get you caught up
on all the things happening in the
Marvel and DC live action cinematic
universes it is Barbershop talk for
nerds uh and also American Gigolo
showtime and that's pretty much it and
you're so talented and we love having
you Eric work and everybody find you I'm
here this couch turns into it it turns
into a bed and I just live here uh but
other than that uh Eric Davis Eric with
a K on Twitter that's usually that's
like my main my main Jam uh that's like
my blog and so follow me over there and
then Fandango just follow Fandango and
and we're doing a bunch of really cool
things our Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania interview is out got a bunch
of big interviews coming out gonna be a
big year and so just follow us uh I
follow this man religiously on Twitter
all of if you want to get the best
entertainment movie news that and you're
up to like the minute caught up follow
this man he's incredible you are both
amazing thank you to our audience for
joining and just a reminder for you guys
to take part in our fan poll vote the QR
code is on the screen right now so just
scan that QR code and cast your vote and
then tune into the Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong golden tomato award episode to see
if what you voted for won we want to
thank you again for joining us on
another episode of the after show this
one was so special near and dear to my
heart and I had two of my favorite
people joining so thanks again to
everybody and we'll see you on the next
one bye
[Music]